the last time you were here you were mr
sex symbol everyone was raving about how
good they felt about chelsea handler
reach out to you because she wanted to
date you
are you having a secret affair with
chelsea
chelsea handler is from the state of
california so she would be
quarantined i need a date who is
not quarantined i can't have somebody
come on a date and stay for 14 days
so i've got to find you a woman who is
inside
new york state yeah some someone who is
close by
and ready for action as they say
can go back you know people you know
people
you can make a recommendation just make
sure she doesn't go on your show
afterwards and you know what
i got to tell you something you're not
crazy i
i happen to like chelsea handler very
much he's a wonderful guest
but my fear for you would be that you
know at some point
she's gonna talk about how you were in
bed or something's gonna happen
where you're like oh god you know what
i'm saying yes
right i want i want somebody who would
never go on your show that's what i want
that's what you're looking for